la jueza tomó esta decisión teniendo
presente el detalle grado de estado de
salud física y mental de julian assange
teme por su vida lo cierto es que la
jueza ha dicho que julian assange
presenta unos cuadros bien complicados
de depresión tiene riesgos de suicidio
ha sido determinado con el síndrome de
asperger de autismo y sus allegados han
dicho que los últimos meses julian
assange desde que está preso ha sido sus
condiciones de salud se han deteriorado
tanto que temen por su vida ahora que la
justicia británica ha fallado en contra
no procede este de extradición a los
estados unidos la justicia eeuu puede
todavía solicitar la extradición de
julian assange puede seguirse apelando
este fallo pero hemos hablado con
personas llegadas a julian assange quien
han dicho que esperan que el presidente
electo joe biden de eeuu tenga compasión
de julian assange y entonces desista de
solicitar esta extradición a ese país